[Music]
so you've had a very interesting and
diverse career can you tell us a bit
more about the thread that's run
throughout all of the different
opportunities well thank you Jenna thank
you everybody for coming it sir it's a
great honor I walked in earlier on and
there's this thing going with all the
people that have been I mean I'm not
heal on masks so I really appreciate you
all coming today
in fact I came in and I saw Elon Musk
and I was like awesome maybe I get to
hear him but sadly I missed that so um
so I was sleep thinking about why apart
from the fact that we've known each
other for many years did didn't know
what I could sort of share that might be
useful might be interesting to you and
given your here given your you're here
at an extraordinary time not only an
extraordinary time in the world what
feels like a a real dis juncture in a
real moment of sort of crisis and and
opportunity in the world but also you're
here at this sort of extraordinary point
in in your lives you know which is this
fantastic sort of moment of of
opportunity and I I was sort of
reflecting on that privilege of the
opportunity of having choices well and I
was remembering when I joined McKinsey
there was this this this terrible talk
that we were given when we joined
McKinsey and this senior partner sat us
down and I think with really good
intentions told us that we were made but
it was not they was downhill from here
but actually we were we could relax
because with our brand on your CV you
are unemployment proof
and it was just there was this horrible
silence in the room and I think that
most people in the room were like here
and I was like oh god how terrible you
know what I think but I think that's
part of the sort of extraordinary thing
about being here is in a way that's true
as well I mean it's not that it wasn't
true what he said at some level it
really was true but I think that
obviously the question was what the
implication was of that whether the
implication is that one needs to be
conscious of the extraordinary privilege
that comes from being in that position
the weight of responsibility that one
has in thinking thoughtfully being
thoughtful about the choices that you
make given that extraordinary that
extraordinary set of opportunities that
you have in front of you and I think
also you know just to be clear that you
know I was very conscious the fact that
I was sitting there in that room not
through the virtue of anything that I
had really done not through the little
tulip or my hard work or my grits or my
anything and not because of something my
grandmother told me when I was a little
bitty boy or you know and none of those
things really I set of four reasons I
really don't understand as a result of
forces completely beyond my control I
had found myself in that position so
again I think that gave me pause to
reflect on on the choices so what I
thought I would sort of try and do is
tell you a little bit for what it's
worth about my story about some of the
things that I've done and some of the
choices I've made and and then we can
have a conversation about you know
whether my guess is 87 percent of you
will think I made lovely choices and
they don't really reflect the choices
you would make and you know maybe you'll
never think about me or this ever again
which is fine but but I hope you'll
think about the choices I hope that we
can you know
have a conversation about what some of
those sort of tensions are so generalize
what the thread was that joined my
career and I have trouble that's a
difficult question turns out that's a
difficult question the fact that they
all begin with it begun with the M is
about the only thread that Jenner could
help me win as we were as we were
preparing for this so yeah I trained as
a musician I I went to Mongolia joined
the kinsey I worked in the media
I really do next going in the media I
worked for many years in mining and and
right now I work in mission investing
which I'm kind of fudging to make the
anything agree what I do now is I work
at the Open Society Foundations
I work for George Soros who is the
philanthropist and the founder of what
is I think it's hard to tell but we
think maybe the second largest
foundations private foundation in the
world focused on human rights focused on
social justice on democracy and
transparency it's quite an extraordinary
place to work in in in many ways it's
been focused on these things for 30
years and it's it's truly a remarkable
institution it has 20 or so thematic
programs that work on everything from
independent journalism to human rights
and criminal justice
it has global programs and foundations
in fact a network of foundations in over
40 countries in the world all of them
with local boards with local staff
deeply rooted in those local communities
we many foundations I think quite
appropriately and quite bravely work on
solving really difficult problems we
work on problems that are insoluble and
we do so in the knowledge that it's
important that people work on those
problems as well
problems that can't
solved that can't be scaled and so we do
we work on injustice and we work on
things like that but or not you know not
soluble I work heading up an economic
advancement program which is part of
that we focus on and we'll talk a little
bit more about that later
and as part of what I do I run the
impact investment arm for the foundation
globally but let me sort of come back to
that and tell you a little bit about
sort of how I got there I I grew up in a
artistic family my father's an actor my
mother's a dancer my brother's a theater
producer the brothers of poet I'm really
the black sheep of the family something
I think over the years of an
embarrassment to the family and I
trained as a classical musician in
London and I I had I was all set for a
career as a conductor I had I had the
hair it's not the talent to be a great
conductor at that age and I I didn't
really know what I was going to do apart
from that I had done that from a very
early age and I was at a dinner party as
a student and I was talking very
animatedly about the things about ideas
that I held very passionately that I
believed in ideas ideas like that the
world is one country and mankind its
citizens ideas that you know men and
women is like two wings of a bird and we
need equality to be able to civilization
to thrive things like this that I
believed in passionately and things like
this that that seemed to be coming
currents and seemed to be coming global
in their in their in their belief and
yet I was talking what would what would
it be like is there a country in the
world where people don't if you went to
a country that was isolated that was cut
off from the rest of the world would
people believe these things anyway would
they are they intrinsic are they
transmitted like I was pretty intense
students really worried about these
things and I think to sort of shut me up
somebody said listen you know you should
go to Outer Mongolia and study the music
there and everybody laughed and I
laughed and I didn't know where Outer
Mongolia was and it just stuck in my
brain so everybody went off and I was
left with this what would be like if you
went to Outer Mongolia and studied the
music so I looked it up I there was no
sort of internet so you know I looked it
up in a phone book doesn't translate I
understand it's okay
big book lots of now many years ago and
I turns out that there was a Mongolian
Embassy in in London and so I called the
Mongolian Embassy and nobody answered
that was the end of the story
which would have been a much not nearly
as good a talk if that really had been
the end of the story it would have would
have been that but I forgot about it
honestly I called and nobody answered
and I I let it go and life is busy and
you move on and I was in my final year
at that as an undergraduate and I
remember one Friday afternoon ice I saw
this piece of paper on my desk with the
telephone number of the Mongolian
Embassy and kind of as a joke I don't
know what I was thinking really I dialed
it without preparation without sort
without strategy I just dialed this
number and of course they answered
Friday afternoon and and they said you
know I couldn't think of what to say I
wasn't prepared I the only thing I could
think of was I couldn't afford to pay my
rent as a student wouldn't have any
money and this guy had told me go to
Outer Mongolia to study the music so I
said I'm going to Mongolia to study the
music and I need money you have a
scholarship the poor guy who regretted
answering the phone
if the Mongolian embassy said no we
don't have any money call the British
Council and
now the British councils like a sort of
British government overseas development
sort of agency that promotes education
and research so I called them British
government offices closed around midday
on a Friday let me tell you so I called
it 5:30 on the Friday afternoon it's
almost no chance anyone's going to
answer this phone and of course you know
they answer and they put me through to
the Mongolian department phone never
rings at the mongolian department so
they answer and the guy says well
actually it's amazing you should call
because we do have one scholarship
actually and not many people require and
actually they do a few people do apply
but they want to do politics and music
is kind of harmless and so why not
that sounds good why do you know the
thing is the application closes on
Wednesday so you need to put an
application in so like I go to this
again so you can't Google anything where
there's no internet so I go to the
library and I look up where is Mongolia
and I and I find a thing and I find a
record of Mongolian music a CD not a CD
a record a whole nostalgia trip here
this is a very retro talk I'm giving um
so we listen to the I listen to this
racket incredible music extraordinary
beautiful sort of just extraordinary
music and a whole series of
extraordinary things happen that week I
won't tell you the whole story one of
them is that the woman who recorded this
made this record 20 years earlier
her name was familiar I called my mother
in Australia why do I know the name of
the woman she said when you were one we
used to live in the basement of her
apartment it used to show you the
Mongolian violins on the wall and the
African drums and things so I thought
okay this is this is a little weird I
have this strange kind of spooky
connection three things happen that week
I made my application and three weeks
later I get the scholarship you know
they ring me up and they say
congratulations you're going for nine
months to Mongolia that's a that was the
sort of thing that you used to have as a
sort of as a sentence in Russia you know
nine months ago
man you know Anna I'm going tonight I'm
going to Mongolia for nine months so you
know that's an extraordinary an
extraordinary thing I'm I I get on this
train in London in in 1988 and I go for
two weeks across Russia across Siberia
and I arrive in Mongolia and it's minus
40 degrees and I don't speak a word of
Mongolian and my life has changed my
life has changed and I spent seven years
in and out of Mongolia and two of those
years I spent living in it living in
with a family of nomads in the western
mountains while they lived there
of course the Soviet Union collapsed the
world changed the Berlin Wall fell and
the kids I've been students with in my
first year surrounded the Parliament I
brought about a revolution in a
political revolution in Mongolia as as
in so many parts of the world and
suddenly what felt like a kind of random
you know none of nobody in my world
understood what I was doing I I have
just dropped off the edge of the earth
suddenly I was in this extraordinary
experience and each year I stayed on for
another year and and so it went on so I
spent seven years in Mongolia and I run
out of research money and along the way
I started a company and just because I
couldn't think of anything else to do I
wasn't a social entrepreneur I was an
entrepreneur I didn't know what that was
I just you know I took the money that we
got from our wedding presents and we
started a travel company and then you
know a year later we sold it not a sort
of Facebook sort of selling it sort of
thing I just gave it to the guy who was
I had running it and he promised he'd
give me some money at some point you
know many years later which he did so I
had this extraordinary experience I
spent seven years in Mongolia I was
married at that stage we went to
Australia and I was about to turn 30 I
was staying in a friend's apartment I
had six weeks before I was going to have
to move in with my parents this is not a
great moment
in my career I don't know if you call it
a career at this stage and I interviewed
with everyone I interviewed for
advertising agency in a bank and of this
a Nevada and any anybody who would sort
of talk to me and everybody wanted to
buy me a drink and what was it like
living with a nomad yaks and I fantastic
of course we're gonna give you a job I
mean you know so I was sort of really
interesting but unemployable you know at
that point in my career and I sat down
with a friend and he said to me you know
what you should do is you should do an
MBA because he said he was at McKinsey
and he said they'll never hire you at
McKinsey but what you should do is use
do an MBA and then they might hire you
to get an MBA you've got a kind of funny
background that's kind of amusing and
then then you've got an MBA you're a
serious person and then maybe you can
get a McKinsey
I thought the funny thing was I thought
wow imagine doing something in order to
be able to do something else afterwards
this was like a he said it's called
strategic thinking sure you know that
sounds smart but for me as someone who
had always maximized the opportunity
that I had in front of me had lived
completely sort of in the moment and had
just seen what were the possibilities
that I could do at any one particular
time that idea of thinking two steps
ahead picking a point and and sort of
driving for it and I tell it as a joke
but genuinely it was a sort of a it was
a sort of an a light bulb moment for me
I knew that it wasn't for me that way of
thinking and and doing an MBA and so I
kind of forgot about it I met a guy at a
dinner party someone said you know
Mongolia how interesting you should come
for an interview and I fact ended up
doing 11 rounds of interviews at
McKinsey and somehow getting at getting
a job with two degrees in music and
seven years in Mongolia
and I was a sort of comic relief you
know the the you know the wild-card sort
of candidate for the year but I had an
extraordinary time but I want to reflect
just for a second on that experience of
sort of being strategic versus being
tactical about thinking about straight
lines in one's career versus nonlinear
sort of parts because I think that you
know and I reflect on this now in the
work that I do because I make a joke
about it and I've spent a great deal of
my life learning about and trying to
think more strategically than then
anyway but even now I I find there is I
mean you couldn't draw the straight line
from music to McKinsey you know the
shortest distance between those two
points I mean you know there was a set
of things you have to do and it wasn't
go to Mongolia there's no there wasn't a
strategic model or a career counselor
that would have given that advice and
yet it was a short assistance for me
that was the nonlinear path between
those two and I think that you know as I
reflect in the work that I do now on the
sort of floors of design thinking and
the flaws of the sort of hubris that
comes with picking a point and driving
towards it the sort of preference for
data and learned experience of lived
experience I I find that the my
experience of my career and my
experience in the work I do
leans much more heavily on a deep
understanding of the complexity and and
trying to be to maintain a sense of
humility in the face of that complexity
in that volatility rather than presuming
to be able to design one's way through
it now you know the place I work now I
think hasn't
has an interesting response to that
which is a deep belief in plural ism
there's a great story about George Soros
and someone was talking to him about a
series of very random grants that he'd
been making and in an area of new
economic thinking just all just
different things that didn't seem to
have any cookie wasn't and someone said
to him you know like you're funding the
haystack in order to find the needle and
he got very agitated and he said you
completely missed the point
there is no needle it's all about the
haystack I love that response I love the
idea that creating environments in which
there's plurality of thinking in which
there a range of options rather than
seeking to prosecute a particular
designed solution and a particular point
outcome I think it's a I think it's a
rational response to the sort of
complexity that we face in our careers
and the sort of complexity we face you
know in the world in which we work so I
had I went from in a few months from
living in the mountains to being an
associate at McKinsey it was kind of a
shock I had five extraordinary years
wonderful years at McKinsey I worked
with people who trained and apprenticed
me it really was an apprenticeship say
they coached me they were patient with
me you know I didn't know what NPV stood
for I didn't know how to switch have you
know to turn Excel on none of these
things so people were generous and
really helped me and I learned a huge
amount from other people I did a whole
range of work a great deal of the work I
did was in media and it was the sort of
web 1.0 and I was all on set to now I
had to have to be a McKinsey partner
it's all about the hair at that stage I
was all set maybe I had the hair and not
the talent again to be a McKinsey
partner but I was absolutely on that
track and somebody offered me the
opportunity to come and run a film
studio and I just
always thought that was the coolest
thing you could possibly do with around
a film studio so I did and I I spent
five years working in the film and
television industry in the UK making
making film and television with with us
studios at the end of which I didn't
know what to do next again and I said
about trying to the one thing that I
felt at that point in my career that I
was really focused on was mastery I saw
that all my career I'd been sort of
jack-of-all-trades doing lots of
different things but that there were
people who got those 10,000 hours people
who really had that deep mastery of a
subject and I really admired that
and so I I said I want to do consulting
I don't want to do advisory work I'm
gonna really try and get a job and and
and I didn't I I almost got three
incredible jobs
I almost the family's got this job at
Pixar this incredible place I had never
been to anywhere so wonderful and I work
in the film business this was dying and
going to heaven and within a week they
just interviewed I've met everybody they
offered me this extraordinary job it was
going to the board on Friday and I was
going to get the offer I was looking at
school so my kids and then I got a call
on the Saturday and something had
happened at the board there was a hiring
freeze and they couldn't talk to me
anymore I was devastated six weeks later
picks our song to Disney so I help to
the best job I I didn't get and there
were two others like this two other
extraordinary jobs that I almost got and
I didn't get and so I found myself doing
more consulting and doing more advisory
and I thought I'd share that just
because otherwise it sounds like this
kind of you know just walking through
the straight path of things that there
were all these things along the way that
I really wanted that you know I failed
to achieve or didn't didn't get or for
whatever reason so I was visiting China
doing due diligence on a deal and
I found myself at a extraordinary table
at the launch of this huge new property
venture and around this was a sort of
the great and the good of China I was
doing due diligence on on an acquisition
there is this extraordinary conversation
it wasn't be a conversation I thought I
would hear when I went to China these
were the heads of the big corporations
these were internet entrepreneurs these
with government officials and the
conversation I thought I would hear in
China was about money and economic
development and opportunity and planes
and you know private jets and things and
instead I heard this extraordinary
conversation about the moral education
of the next generation
I had never sat at a table of people who
were thinking about their about their
society in this extraordinary
fundamental way was very exciting and
very challenging and I realized that
anywhere in the world that Beijing was
probably the place where the future of
the planet was sort of being thought
about and was being shaped intentionally
or unintentionally by an extraordinary
group of people so I went out on the
balcony and I called my wife and I said
I've got it the whole thing about
getting a job and not mastery when we
moved to China instead and by the end of
the phone call my wife had agreed and we
put our kids on a plane about six months
later and we moved to China and I didn't
have a job or anything and we figured
that we would learn about China that we
would I something would work out and we
thought that it was an important time to
expose our family and ourselves to that
what was going on in China and as I
arrived some of those friends at that
dinner asked me to come and help them
with the IPO of their their company I
didn't know anything about real estate I
didn't know anything about China I
didn't know anything about capital
markets but they said it was okay
because they trusted me and in that
environment of complexity
an important thing to rely on is trust
human relationships again not learned
experience in a resume with the right
skills but
very human very direct qualities that
could be relied on and as of that I had
an extraordinary experience worked with
them on the IPO was introduced to
Goldman Sachs who asked me to work with
them and I did for the next seven years
as an advisor but funnily enough on
Mongolia where there was a big wave of
interest in mining and natural resources
through that I got to meet the chief
executive of one of the largest mining
companies in the world who was making a
six seven billion dollar investment in
Mongolia they were going to be 35% of
the GDP of the country how did they
behave in that environment how do you
what does it look like to be a corporate
citizen with that degree of influence on
Honor Society and so asked me to come
and help them and I spent four or five
years working with them on that and so
at the end of my time in China thinking
about how to return to the West I had a
call from a headhunter about this job
and have been very privileged to to take
this opportunity so that's a long
winding journey and M is about the only
thread that I can draw through that
except I think the other thing is
responding to complexity and is being
open to opportunities that don't look
like the next linear move and that don't
necessarily make strategic sense but
make deep tactical deep immediate sense
thank you thank you so much for sharing
such a beautiful and diverse story and
coming see what the work you're doing
now can you talk a little bit more about
what economic advancement means to you
and to the Soros economic momentum yes
so there are so I'll sort of tell you
our strategy how about that and see if I
can convince you and you can call me on
it if you don't if you don't buy it so
we we started with the name I was told
that the name of the program was the
economic advancement program not
economic development and we went away
and we thought about what is economic
development
what's the purpose of economic
development sort of it's become a an end
in its own right the purpose of economic
development is economic developers
economic growth is economic growth we
felt that as a foundation focused on
human rights and democracy that we
should question that that we should ask
why not why is economic development
valuable and important but what our role
in that might be and so we have chosen
to focus on that aspect of economic
development that promotes open societies
that is instrumental to developing the
open society I think that you know if
you build a mind you can be forgiven for
thinking it generates money it
contributes to GDP it's a good thing
that's economic development China has
had a huge amount of Economic
Development but economic advancement the
development of a society that goes along
with that economic development is
different and you could argue that
actually social justice is a trade off
that people are being asked to make in
many places against economic development
people are being offered those two
things as a choice I think we used to
think that they go hand in hand you do
one the other comes to get more
democracy you get more economic growth
it hasn't worked out like that and so as
a program we're being intentional about
focusing on those forms of economic
development that contribute to the open
society the second part of our strategy
is to is that we see we place investment
as part of the toolkit that we want a
deployer to address these problems there
is this there's a great sort of I mean
there's no question that that it will
talk maybe more about this is a question
of impact investment and investment is
it is a valuable and powerful tool
markets can be powerful forces but at a
very basic level anybody who is invested
in an emerging market impact business
knows that very often the failure is not
because of a lack of capital money is
rarely the
the failure is almost always the policy
environment in which that investment
takes place or the lack of capacity in
that society to absorb and to and to
work with those investments or the lack
of civil society was able to hold
government's accountable and so we're
trying to take a systemic view of these
problems I think the next wave of impact
investment is going to be focused on
solving problems and maybe not solving
problems but engaging with local people
in systems and trying to address
multiple points in those and so we felt
as a program that we wanted to deploy
grants to civil society policy in order
to work with governments and we wanted
to work with impact investment where
there is a need for sort of private
capital the third thing is that we are
focused on we're conscious that in many
of these systems there's an ecosystem of
many players already existing and that
what is important is that we we try to
enable and very often don't play the
primary role ourselves so we have been
intentional in building a the capacity
to build collective action there are
many problems for which again capital is
not the problem
lots of people engaging and this is not
a problem there are many players already
there's a sort of fetish for the new
there's a there's a desire to found
something and start something and do
something new and make an intervention
and actually what we're trying to do in
many of these is simply convene existing
players and provides the middleware to
sort of join them together and finally
we've focused on participation I think
one of the real challenges with impact
investment with economic development is
not what's being done but the way it's
been the way it's been done decisions
are made in rooms in which the people
who are the so called beneficiaries of
these investments and so-called
beneficiaries of these interventions are
not present they're not designing the
outcomes they're not even in the
conversation and
so we've focused really on how we can
build a more participatory approach to
this let me give you an example I was in
Sri Lanka in the north of Sri Lanka and
talking with a senior minister there
about their experience of the last sort
of 10 years
post-conflict and there are enough brits
in the room who will get the Monty
Python reference here but it was a kind
of a funny moment because one of his
because he said what did that regime
ever do for us what economic development
did they ever bring to us one of the
people in his in his team said well they
built the roads all right they built the
roads but apart from the roads what did
they ever do for us someone said well
the school and we have got 3G now that's
really nice yeah oh and the clinics here
the clinics have been ok apart from the
roads and the schools and the clinics
and the telecommunication what did that
regime ever do for us and it went on it
was like that you know the Monty Python
what did the Romans ever do for us the
point of the story for me was that then
he said at the end he said you know what
it doesn't matter what they did because
we weren't involved they never asked us
what we wanted so we don't have cars to
drive on the roads we don't have
teachers to be in the schools we have
this economic development that you gave
us but we'll burn it all down because
we're not involved and I think that that
speaks to the importance of people being
and having a sense of agency over the
direction of and the crafting of the
solutions and the crafting of the
responses to the to the city to the
problems and so without that
participation we think it's going to be
very hard for any of these interventions
any of this money any of this investment
to work and so those are sort of four
aspects that we're trying to build into
our approach to to what is it hard still
you know impact investments and grant
making and there are others I think you
know the AMA do i Comedy Hour Network
are really fellow travelers in this
regard and I think there is a new
generation of those who are looking more
systemically at many of these problems
in this way and and more portly as you
think about your take on impact
investing in the industry and your space
within that how do you think about that
and how do you think about shaping the
industry yeah I mean look I I'm new to
this space and I'm learning and so I I
don't want to sound like like I have the
answer
and I think that there has been such
extraordinary work that has been done by
many people from here and and around the
world in this space and in finding ways
of applying the power of markets to
solving problems and I and I find it
inspiring and I find it a you know I I
to me my career has sort of converged on
exactly this on how come one use the
power of markets how can one use the
power of and the scale and all of these
things that resources that the private
sector has to do what is really most
urgent and important so I'm not in any
way criticizing critiquing naysaying
the extraordinary work that's been done
and I get why so many people sitting in
your shoes at this moment of opportunity
in your life see this as an opportunity
but I you know there are aspects of it
either that trouble me or let me put it
this way if there's going to be a second
wave of impact investment if there's
going to be a next generation that's
going to come from the impact investment
my question to you is what is that going
to look like because I think there's a
bunch of people who are set up to make
sure that that next way that next wave
of impact investment
is bigger and more retail and more
muscular and a whole lot like what the
kind of other previous generation of
non-impact investment looked like and
you've got to figure out whether that's
a good thing you know so it's exciting
that TPG is everybody is an impact
investment right TPG is going to do
impact investment Goldman Sachs is doing
impact investment you've got to work out
whether that's happening because we're
lowering the bar on what impact is or if
it's because we're scaling up the
response and this is everybody genuinely
getting it and getting on board I think
we have to at least ask ourselves the
question whether using the tools we have
to at least be conscious that we're
using the tools to solve problems and
the tools were using were the very
things that contributed to the problems
in the first place
that at least should trouble us it at
least should ask us to ask some
questions about whether we are sort of
complicit in perpetuating and I mean I
asked myself a question where do we
think we're kind of whether we think we
can sort of get away with this like you
know this system and these tools have
done such an extraordinary job in the
West fund managers and investment banks
and you know that the sort of global
financial systems just does an
extraordinary job of solving social
problems in the developed world
now suddenly fund managers are going to
solve deep intractable problems in the
emerging world sort of seems quite
hopeful we have two objectives in our
program one is to champion marginalized
voices in economic systems and the other
is to address those systems themselves
to question the fundamental premises of
those systems itself and we try and do
both I wonder whether the next
generation of impact investing the next
wave of impact investment
is going to do the latter or not or
whether it's really sort of complicit in
in sustaining a system that has caused
such deep inequality and given the scale
of the problem that we face the scale of
the global inequality and the scale of
the resentment that's felt the idea that
we can so sorry it's all so good now
we're going to just do the same thing
but we're going to do it a little bit
then it's all going to work out I think
is is quite I think it's wishful
thinking or at least if you should give
us pause so my hope is that the next
generation that's this next wave an
impact investment I guess that you will
be going into building will take a
different approach you know we can't
grow ourselves out of inequality it's a
lovely idea we can sort of inclusively
grow ourselves out of it none of us are
going to have to give up anything that
we that we that we have experienced all
we have but the math doesn't work can
never catch up like that and so I think
we're sort of avoiding the difficult
question so I think the next generation
the next wave of impact investment is I
hope will answer those five questions I
think that you know a great friend of
mine
Alan Guerra de artes gave a talk in
Aspen a few years ago and he faced a an
extraordinary room named after a great
Titan of of capitalism and we have to
realize all of us and me included that
I'm here we're here as a as a result of
the largesse of that system as well you
know and I'm very conscious of that
we're very conscious of that in what we
do and he asked that audience we're
about generosity and justice and I
encourage you to look it up it's it's a
fantastic speech and he said you know
are we simply going to get together and
talk about doing more good or are we
going to actually have to ask whether we
have to do less harm whether there's a
more fundamental reimagining of some of
the basic systems and assumptions that
that is necessary so my hope is
the second wave of impact investment is
going to be prepared to take much more
risk it's really going to be prepared to
do to be much more fundamentally
addressing the systemic issues that
underpin these and not simply the sort
of application of build tools in a
slightly new way thank you and before
one last question before we open up to
the audience if you think about this
balance between doing good and doing
well and the potential tension between
the two how do you think about that yeah
it's a really difficult question I'd
love to hear your answers to that
problem just mine I came on a great
quote the other day I'm going to read it
um because I I look I I don't have great
so I'm not as you know you know I'm not
an economist I'm not a political
scientist so I take quite a sort of
personal view of these things every this
is a great quote every choice we make as
an employer or an employer producer or
consumer borrower or lender a benefactor
or a beneficiary leave the trace and we
have a moral duty to lead a coherent
life where our economic decisions are in
accordance with our ideals and our aims
are matched by our actions I think
that's that coherence that you know
you're going to have to figure out we're
going to have to figure out our
coherence in our personal life you know
what does that match look like and our
coherence in our in our professional
lives and our investing lives because
you can dress it up in lots of ways but
at the end of the day it becomes I think
it's a very personal a personal question
and I think at the end of the day you
know it's a moral question I really do
I Bono has been talking about impact
investment recently and you know he
talks about so many things I think very
very effectively but in that he says
look investing is not
immoral it's a moral it's a moral it
just depends on who's using it and how
it gets used and that's true sort of I
mean I kind of believe that as well but
the economic arc of the universe is
short and it tends towards self-interest
if we're honest and I think that there
is an undertow that the incentives and
waiver system is structured there is an
undertow that pulls us towards
self-interest and towards the
accumulation and the concentration of
wealth and I think just have to be
honest about it we have to we have to
acknowledge that it's not a moral it
isn't a neutral system that can just be
pointed in this way or pointed in that
way and magic happens it's not it's
structured in a way that pulls all of us
in our personal lives and in our work in
one way and it takes effort to tilt the
board the other way that's all it takes
arithmetic it takes sacrifice and I just
I think trivializing that by saying you
can absolutely have your cake and eat it
it's not a problem have you you know
what you can do we can have our cake and
let them eat it we know how the last
time that worked out didn't work out so
well so the idea of sort of inclusive
growth and shared value and these things
I don't think that they're wrong I just
think they're insufficient to the scale
of the problem and so I think this next
generation is going to have to this next
wave it's going to have to really
address these very very very fundamental
issues and we're going to have to think
more fundamentally about the problem
thank you thank you so much Sean and I
love to open up to questions from the
audience we had two roaming mics and
it'd be great if you could introduce
yourself and share a little bit about
your background as you ask a question
and actually specifically if you're
going to ask me a question I want to
know what your answer is because you
know coming up with a smart question no
all the hands went down immediately
we've had a fantastic no questions at
all now I'd love to hear what your what
your view is on this please hey my name
is Patrick Daniel I really enjoy to a
personal story and journey that you
shared initially want to ask you about
the different turning points and how you
balance focus and you know the
serendipity that you like sort of talked
about but I think you know as we then
talked about basically all these big
issues around the world I want to talk
to you about what are your thoughts on
decentralization as a major theme of the
21st century and as a possible solution
of solving all of these problems and
since you asked that I shall also answer
my own questions when you think about
eventually I do anything like blockchain
technology and the social implications
of blockchain technology and all these
different decentralized trends that was
seeing can really undermine the global
you know power infrastructure that we
have and so I think this is a huge
paradigm shift which will be very
difficult to like go through because the
existing global elite will not you know
just give it away without a fight so so
from your perspective with all the
experiences you've had
I'm just cured to understand you know
how you understand all these um you know
these big trends it's a great question
do not ask us to you and say we can I do
you want to just let me think let's do
want to sound okay um well so you know I
think the question you have boils down
to power and where this power sit and
how does power get moved around and
clearly the emergence of new
technologies can cause significant
shifts and can cause significant
ruptures in established balance of power
which is what makes them so troubling
and so exciting at the same time what is
clear though is that the system is
highly adaptable and highly resistant to
that change and it absorbs disruptive
elements and it brings them back in it's
my point about impact investment
potentially highly disruptive
potentially risk that it gets reabsorbed
and and brought back in as those
technologies can as well I think the
question you know one of the questions
that we're looking at at the moment is
the question of digital identity it's a
question of identity and we are looking
at in the context of the refugee
situation and it's one of the it's one
of the most sort of popular themes for
impact investment at the moment is new
technologies that can that can that can
be disruptive but we have to ask
ourselves who do we want to be
controlling the means of identity by
which we are have a presence in the
world you know there is a very real
possibility that within two or three
years that will sit in the hands of you
know major global corporations many of
whom are burstin live you know not
within many miles of this of this hall
that's a real possibility there's a real
possibility though that governments will
establish in India has done an
extraordinary job of it something that
is both in equal measure those of you
aware about that the digital stack the
India stack is an extraordinary
development that holds possibly equally
exciting and terrifying consequences and
so I think you know with the Open
Society Foundations I make two
observations one is the problem in this
area is not a lack of technology and
unlocking lack of investment the problem
is collective action the problem is that
it requires governments and civil
society and the private sector to have
to really come together in order to be
able to find the solution that will
respect rights and will shift power and
will do so at scale and be effective for
you know for marginalized voices that's
a very complicated problem and what
tends to have
is that is that the private sector with
capital with you know free of regulation
increasingly free of regulation moves
quickly to fill that gap and I think
that's you know we should think we
should be we should be concerned about
how that happens we should we should
watch that very carefully but I think
it's very exciting at the same time this
and radical shah i'm KO present here at
the stanford tech innovation club of
nine hundred faculty students at alumni
and an advisor to the sustainable
development goals philanthropy platform
which is a catalytic platform for
collaboration within countries
contextual but also global for informing
policy and funding scalable innovation
very very inspiring to hear your life
journey thank you for sharing that and
especially the nonlinear part my
question is around impact investment the
point Aegina touched on profit versus
mission looking from an impact
entrepreneurs perspective how does an
mission-driven entrepreneur who wants to
really be very mission driven achieve
this fight self-interest and really the
earlier you mentioned that economic
development and social justice may
really be a trade off and my own since
you wanted us to share our views as i've
been observing and thinking my own
senses that in impact investment to it's
not always a win-win it's often a
trade-off for that entrepreneur having
meant at many profit versus mission what
is some advice for that entrepreneur and
second question is what is the role of
international or universal policy for
impact investing because there aren't
two panels being funded by organization
from different countries it seems to be
becoming a very global ecosystem the
rules are different in each country is
there a role here for the UN or other
other forms of international policy for
impact investing that can help
especially to fight the self-interest so
it is truly focused on inequality and
the problems addressed by the SDGs yeah
you know more about this than I do this
is brilliant what do you I would love to
hear your thought on the first one just
just to minute what's your just give us
your your view on that first
we won't be able to do all of this I did
something I think a lot about I don't
have a strong opinion because I don't
know that I have seen many entrepreneurs
I founded a local chapter for a show
Casa de Ashoka fellows so many of them
who are mission driven entrepreneurs
there most of them traditional ones are
not for profits and nonprofits in the
limited debt and then there are several
impact entrepreneurs who are for
professor in the data set I've seen one
thing I've observed is that the ones who
are not focusing on profit seem to be
even more mission driven as my
subjective opinion and observation and
I've seen that across most that I've
seen and I don't know if that's because
they can optimize just for one goal or
if they're really more mission driven
people being drawn towards purely
mission and I'm also from the for-profit
side I see the value of sustainability
and yet I think about this quite a bit
so I don't have an answer but I have a
hypothesis that perhaps the the caliber
of entrepreneur that's going towards
mission alone is more mission driven and
that's an that's my current hypothesis
but I would love to change that because
these entrepreneurs are always looking
for fun so sure I don't know what the
answer is still fought to change that
sure um that's I mean it's a great huge
question and it's a great question I I
would love to see so I think it's some
level the question is do we have to make
a trade-off I want to just be clear what
I was saying before about economic
development and social justice I think
that increasingly many places in the
world are people are being offered those
as mutually exclusive alternatives that
they have to make a choose one versus
the other and I think we believe very
much that there is common ground that in
fact the space in which economic
development can enable social justice is
vibrant and and and contested space but
nonetheless filled with opportunity
there's another level of the question
though which is is there any trade-off
that you have to make between
you know the profit motive and the
impact motive can you have your cake and
eat it and I think you can tell from
what I've said before that I think that
there are trade-offs that we have to
make I think simply in all cases
imagining that one can do both without
compromise is unrealistic
I think it's unrealistic to the
generations of people that have worked
with good intent and with deeply
thoughtful you know in deeply thoughtful
ways on very intractable deep problems
of of of poverty I think it's it's just
magical thinking to imagine that that
there are scalable simple solutions that
can that can address those at the very
simple level patience in capital the
requirement for much longer time frames
itself is a compromise with the
short-term you know
profit maximizing position and I think
that's true of entrepreneurs but I think
we have to ask the question about you
know what is enough and and and whether
we are prepared to make that effort and
make those sacrifices too and make make
those trade-offs because at an
individual level and at the level of a
single investment I believe in many
cases if not all cases a real trade-off
has to be made but we have to be
comfortable doing that there is a name
for transactions where one person does
well at the expense of others it's not
investment it's seeding it's it's we
don't need I mean you know who there's a
name for those transactions they're just
wrong and the idea that we need to have
a name called that of impact investment
for a transaction in which externalities
are considered and various stakeholders
are respected and both parts both
parties come out in a reasonable way
that that should be called impact
investment that seems odd to me because
we have another name already for the
other and it's actually you know leaving
so why don't we just maybe this next
generation of impact investment
ultimately will reclaim the notion of
investment as a reasonable and fair and
balanced transaction anything else seems
it seems you know terrifying to me thank
you so much Shawn I'm so sorry we're out
of time it's so appreciate you taking
the time to be here today and thank you
for
[Applause]